Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, on a une question de Linda,
qu'on va aller écouter :
« Je veux savoir s'il y a des services
au niveau montréalais qui servent les autochtones? »
Alors Linda, tu me demandes s'il y a des services
qui existent à Montréal pour les Premières Nations.
Oui, on appelle ça les centres d'amitié.
Il y a d'ailleurs aussi des centres
qui sont qui sont utilisés,
qui sont connus pour ce qui est
des questions liées à l'itinérance,
ou liées aux femmes qui sont victimes
de violences. Mais, pour en connaître un peu plus, justement, sur les violences dont
sont victimes les Premières Nations
et les nations autochtones,
je pense que tu peux aller vers des commissions,
comme la Commission vérité et réconciliation,
qui a beaucoup servi à éclairer,
justement, les Québécois
et les Canadiens sur les réalités
et sur l'histoire du Canada par rapport
aux pensionnats, par exemple, et qui explique
dans le fond un peu la base de beaucoup
des autres réalités des Premières Nations.
Je pense aussi qu'on vient d'avoir la
commission Viens. On a aussi
présentement le Bureau des enquêtes indépendantes
qui a maintenant un agent de
liaison autochtone. Donc, des fois,
les ressources vont venir de chez vous,
mais c'est surtout l'intérêt qui est très
nouveau, qui vient justement du grand
courant de réconciliation
et que des fois, ça peut être difficile
parce que les violences, on ne s'en rend pas compte,
Ça peut être aussi quand on décide
d'ignorer les questions qui touchent
les Premières Nations. Donc, je te remercie
beaucoup Linda d'avoir posé
la question.
C'est-à-dire que ton intérêt est ouvert
et, justement, tu vas avoir l'oeil beaucoup plus
alerte quand tu vas voir
des injustices, quand tu vas entendre
des histoires sur les femmes assassinées
et disparues ou sur la surreprésentation
des enfants à la DPJ
pour les Premières Nations.
Je pense que ça, c'est déjà une partie
de la solution. C'est d'avoir le public
québécois intéressé à ces réalités-là.
Donc, merci beaucoup pour ta question,
en espérant que j'ai pu y répondre.
N'hésitez pas à nous en envoyer, s'il vous
plaît, et n'hésitez pas, surtout, à partager les vidéos.
Passez une belle semaine!